Hogan's Alley, are you tough enough to join the FBI?
That's amazing. I can't believe that's what they had to slug.
Are you a bad enough dude?
You gotta leave that- the- our laughter in there.
Yeah, I am gonna leave that in there and then it's gonna go into the thing and then it's gonna go into this.
And welcome to NEStalgia, a chronological exploration of every NES game released in North America.
I'm Mike Esposito.
I'm Sean Tresmond.
And I'm Joe Castew.
Joe, you fell asleep at the wheel there for a second.
Oh, is that- I delayed?
You know, I'm not- I'm not with you guys.
He's still- Oh yeah, yeah, yeah, it's true.
Yeah, he's still coming in via tele-satellite link.
Yep, you're at the-
Once the listeners are listening to this episode, I'll sound exactly-
Right, that's not gonna sound right at all.
Okay, well anyway, you're at the Korean Olympic Games, right?
Yeah, I'm from Baghdad. Yes, of course that's where I am.
Wow, you haven't been Baghdad, I haven't been Korea.
You're really good, Joe, in some great places.
Another thing to go with that. I don't tell them where I'm going.
Okay, so we're talking about Hogan's Alley today, as you might have guessed from that introduction.
Again, all the introductions are just the back of the boxes on the NES.
And that one was actually beautiful.
Yeah. This game, I never got a link that I was on the FBI.
Like, I never felt-
I didn't either.
I'm gonna probably get like a police training thing, but not the-
Right. Not specifically the FBI.
Right, I never really felt like-
Yeah, police training, for sure.
That's actually a great way to segue into initial impressions, Sean.
This is another light gun game.
Um, it's definitely serviceable.
It obviously doesn't have the same lasting power as Duck Hunt, or the future lasting power of Duck Hunt 2.
Um, but-
For Nintendo Switch.
Please refer to the Duck Hunt episode if you have no idea what Sean's talking about.
Um, but I think just because like, they're really not moving targets, it's-
It's really just like, can you tell who to shoot quickly?
Like, there's no depth to this game.
It's a police training simulator.
Like, there's like, mode A is just like-
Well, hold on, hold on. You take a stare in a second, okay?
Oh. Let's get some of Joe's initial impressions.
Oh, I'm sorry. My initial impression was that I was kind of impressed that it did something so different than Duck Hunt.
I mean, it's hard to not compare it to Duck Hunt, because it's the only light game we've played so far.
Yeah, it did a pretty good job of-
of being a decent light gun game and accomplishing something totally different than Duck Hunt.
I had fun with it. I thought it was a great game.
All right. And yeah, as these two guys have mentioned, it's an NES Zapper game.
Um, our second.
Uh, and my initial impression was also that, uh, it's very different.
than Duck Hunt, but I actually found it kind of charming.
Uh, I think is the right word.
Um, in the sense that like, I was like, huh, it was different enough from Duck Hunt that I-
I actually never thought of Duck Hunt while playing this.
Like, never during the gameplay was I like, huh, how is this like, or is this not like Duck Hunt?
It was kind of like its own game and I enjoyed that.
Uh, so Sean, as promised, take us through, uh, Mode A.
Okay. Um, Mode A is, uh,
I think it's boring.
It's in- I like that they contextualize everything that they're doing as like a police training
thing, but it's really just, uh, how fast is your reaction time.
And there's not- and there's no like, there's no time where it actually tells you how fast
your reaction time was.
Yeah. You just kind of like- It's just like, at the top it says like how much time you have.
Right. And, and, and I agree with like, there's, there's just not a lot there.
Yeah. This is a mode that, uh, and we were talking about this with Duck Hunt too, where it's like
one duck is kind of just like a beginner's like mode.
But there's still something there for, um, for one duck where it's like, it's still can
be fun. Right.
And it can still be fun if that's the only modes you ever play.
I highly doubt that this lineup game where three people come in and then one of them
or two of them happens to be the bad guy and you have to shoot them fast.
I highly doubt that that doesn't get old after a while.
Right. For me, it got old very quickly.
Yeah. It felt, it felt kind of to me like it was, it was like an introduction.
I was like, this is what this game is.
And it wasn't too long before I was like, okay, so where do they go from here?
Like what's next? Right.
And I mean like, and also there's just, there's not enough characters to, to make it that different.
Right. Like how many are there total?
Six? Nine? I think, I think it's six.
Well, I think there's seven.
Seven. Okay. Well, I know there's a, there, there's an equivalent or at least in my head there was an, I do not.
But there was a lady.
Yeah. Lady, gang A, gang B.
Right. I'm joking.
I have no idea. But there was a, there were three bad guys that looked just like three of the good guys.
Like there was the professor with the, with the brown coat and hat, but then there was
a bad guy with like brown hair.
You think he's a professor?
It's, it's called professor.
Oh, he's called professor.
Okay. I thought that was a pretty interesting stereotype there for a second, but no, he's a professor.
Okay. Right.
So Sean, wait, you sound like you know the names of these characters.
At the beginning of each round, they, at the beginning of each round, they show you
all of the, the names of the characters.
So her name is actually Lady.
Lady. It's Lady. Wow.
The Duchess. Okay.
Um, yeah.
And I, I did, I did like that Joe.
I did like that they were close enough.
Yeah. I found myself accidentally shooting the innocent guy that looked like the bad guy.
Right. Until I kind of came up with a strategy for it, but we'll get into that.
But real, real quick, just on, on these characters.
Does, um, there is one of them that just looks shirtless.
Um, yes, yes.
Is he not? I don't, he's not shirtless.
I'm pretty sure that that's supposed to be, uh, like a trench coat of, of some sort.
Oh. I thought he was shirtless.
No, I, I always thought that was a trench coat.
I'm actually, I was actually confused about which character you were talking about.
I thought you guys were talking about the red curly haired guy.
Oh no. Uh, the guy, no, no, the guy with the black hat.
Yeah, no, yeah. He, he definitely, definitely looks like a trench coat to me.
I don't know. I was, I was getting a much different vibe.
I mean, he has a very nice trench coat.
Don't get me wrong. It's definitely like, there's some good, that could be Michael Kors for all we know.
It's nice material.
He probably stole it.
Sure, sure. Um, but, wow, actually we're watching some gameplay right now.
Sean is proving to me that they, the placement of some of those buttons look exactly like
nipples. They are, they are nipple buttons.
Is that what they are? They're buttons, huh?
They're buttons, yeah. I think it's open for interpretation.
Alright, well, okay.
Um, alright, so that's Mode.
There's really nothing else to talk about there.
Mode B. Let's just move on to Mode B.
Which, which Sean, I'm gonna fight you here cause I see your face.
Yeah. Friends at home, can't see Sean's face right now.
He seems disappointed.
I'm just gonna nip that right in the butt right here and say that, uh, Mode B is, is a
masterpiece over Mode A.
Okay? Of course.
And no, no, no. But like, to the point where it's actually, it's, it's innovative.
I, I like the whole like, that, this is where the charm comes in from my initial impressions.
Mode B won me over.
I'm with you on that, Mike.
Yeah. Charming.
I don't, I don't know if it's, if it's absolutely amazing, but I had a lot of fun with Mode B.
I had more fun with Mode B than, than, uh, certain, uh, Duck Hunt time, you know?
Okay, well, let's, let's slow down there.
And Duck Hunt's one of our unanimous essential games.
Yeah. So I think like, I think for me it's like, what's interesting about Hogan's Alley's Mode B is like,
so for those of you that don't know, it takes you out of the police academy and out of the lineup.
And instead you kind of are going through like a,
An obstacle course.
Yeah. Like an obstacle course.
It's like a town set up.
There's like a saloon. It's like, not really a saloon because it's not 1800s, but.
I love that, uh, that when, after you, you know, you take out anyone in the, uh, in the house or whatever,
you start walking to the next location and there's like a musical equivalent of going,
It's like a, like a, like an upbeat little, like you're just going for a stroll,
ready to kill the next couple of bad guys.
Joe, I would like to play that sound effect right now if I haven't already.
Um. Okay.
And that was the sound effect.
I hope. Mode B though, for me, just for the record, did anybody else feel like it was also harder
in the sense that you didn't have as much time to shoot some of the people?
Like I was missing a lot more.
I mean, there will be times where the entire bad guy is obscured by something except for
maybe like his, his gun.
Um, so I think it's definitely, it's definitely harder to, um, hit a smaller object.
Okay. I, I just felt like, and it wasn't like, it wasn't the game's fault.
I just noticed that like compared to the generosity in mode a mode B was like, there were times
where two bad guys would come across the screen.
I'd be able to shoot the first one.
And before I could even like point at the second one, it would be like, oh, you missed
him. It was like, well, give me a chance.
Yeah. Like, geez.
But you know, I guess, you know, for the police academy, you gotta be good.
Right. It also took me a minute to notice that before each round, it would say in the top, how much
time you were going to have to shoot.
Oh, I didn't notice that. That's interesting.
It would say like, oh, it would be sometimes as low as like 0.6 seconds.
Like it would be, and then other times it'd be like two seconds, but yeah.
If you got to a later round and it was like 0.8 seconds and you had to, and there were
two bad guys on screen, it was very difficult to get the most.
Yeah. You had to be very quick.
Gotcha. I don't disagree with you guys about the, actually, I don't know if Joe mentioned it
at all, but I do like the, the overall aesthetic of it.
I do like that it's framed as such, but going into the third mode, this doesn't even seem
like it's a part of the same game.
It seems more like a bonus mode.
Yeah. You know, like just like something, something fun that they put in.
But this is, this is actually the part of the game that I liked the most.
Yes. I also agree.
I had no idea of the origins of this tin can thing cause it's in, uh, series
Smash Brothers and this is now, uh, it's in Hogan's alley.
But I think for me, what was so enjoyable about this was that you get very cocky about
it at first.
You're like, Oh, that's it.
Like you shoot the tin can across and you're like, of course I'm going to get the 5,000
point one. And that alone is just like one can 5,000 points.
Very tough challenge because you have to, they aimed it in such a way that like you almost
always hit that top brick.
Yeah. You know, or you have to get very close to dropping the can in order to get it into the
fight. You have to let it get very dangerously close to, to going out of bounds before you can
get it into the 5,000.
I just want to say what we're talking about for if you haven't played for some reason.
So, uh, this mode is not called mode C it's called trick shot.
And you have these tin cans and they're just like, you just trying to shoot them from one
end to the other while they spin.
And if they drop to the bottom of the screen, they're gone.
And then you have to like, uh, land them on platforms and the highest platform is worth
like nothing. And the lowest platform is worth 5,000 points.
The cans are free falling.
And then when you shoot them, you bounce them back up into a new arc.
Yeah. They could have benefited from like a cityscape in the background or something.
Instead, they just opted for black.
Um, but whatever.
It's a night cityscape. Yeah.
It's just night. Yeah.
Night in the powers out.
I think I felt like it feels, it feels good.
It feels mini game ish though.
Well, sure. And you could argue the whole game is a mini game.
Like the whole, each mode is just a short little burst of thing.
But I feel like with trick shot, I never really felt like I, you know, like again, the high
score thing, take that out of the way.
It's just also, I never felt like I should have stuck with it longer.
Like nothing visually stimulating was happening.
Um, it was like, once I nailed the 5,000 point shot thing, Oh, what after a couple of
times, I was like, okay, I got my fill.
No, I felt like it was a good way to have like something a little different, uh, because
mode a and mode B were all about like the decision making.
And, and to be honest, it never felt like it never really felt like you could miss a shot
in mode a and mode B.
It was more about like making the right decision or deciding quickly enough.
Like, right. You could get two shots off in the, in the 0.8 seconds.
It's just making the right decisions in the 0.8 seconds, which is really fun.
It's really interesting. But then when I really think about it, I'm like, I don't really need the gun for this.
Like I'm just kind of picking a side of the screen or a part of the screen.
Like I never felt like I just had like a and B over their heads.
Yeah. I never felt like I missed or was in danger of missing in that.
So I mean, I had fun. The zapper does add a little bit of, um, you know, it adds an extra element to those.
Like I definitely think it would have been even more, but like I would not have even
said these modes were interesting if I was just using, uh, the buttons.
Like I think the zapper, like a little bit of flair to it.
And I think like also the, uh, sorry, Joe, you, you want to say something else?
No, just while, while I was using the, you know, using the zapper on it at first, I was
like, Oh, this is, you know, very cool.
I'm aiming. And then I realized like, Oh, my aiming is not really doing that much.
Like pretty easy to aim at these guys.
But the cans is where I was like, Oh, this kind of adds like now, if I want to get a
little bit of my like sharp shooting in, you kind of got to like be a little more precise
with where you're shooting the cans and when you're shooting the cans.
So it's like two different, uh, styles of playing.
Sure. They're just, they just compliment each other.
Well, one little stray thing I wanted to say about this game is like, I feel like each
of these modes have, and not, not that they're not fun, but they have so little going on in
terms of like who you're supposed to be or what you're supposed to be doing aside from
just shooting these guys.
I feel like the title of the game has more personality than I think it deserves.
Who is Hogan?
What is going on in his alley?
It almost makes you think of Hogan's heroes.
Is that what that is?
No, no, no. Nothing like that.
That was a TV show.
Um, no, I, I know.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. No, I'm just saying like, it just makes me think that like, they were like, Oh, that's
popular at the time. Let's just name this something similar.
Like is Hogan. Maybe like, maybe that's like the connection.
Maybe Hogan was the, uh, uh, the director of the FBI in the eighties.
I don't know. Yeah.
Uh, it's, it's funny.
I never thought about what the title meant until you just said that.
But, uh, so just one thing that, uh, I want to clarify too, that this, this mode, you're
trying to get the cans onto the, onto the 5,000 is the ideal, uh, platform to land your can
on, but there are also other layers that are easier.
There's an 800, a 300 platform that are higher up easier to get it on and less dangerous of
dropping the can. Um, and there's also a little 100 platform that you kind of get stuck on.
But, um, so it's all about like deciding which value of points you want.
It's funny too. Like how much that like small little platform that's worth the least like that you're like,
Oh, that's like kind of just in the middle of nowhere.
But like somehow your cans always bounce off and go back down to the bottom.
And it's like, as soon as it lands on that, that's it.
It's a hundred points and you're done.
They have it designed in a way too, that like if you're going for the 5,000, that, that little
100 platform gets in your way the most.
Okay. So I had to look it up just because we were talking about the name.
And so this is me cheating.
I'm not actually knowledgeable.
Hogan's alley is a tactical training facility of more than 10 acres operated by the FBI training
academy. So that actually gives the whole context.
Now we get where the FBI comes in and all that stuff.
So I want to say that I don't feel stupid.
Okay. I definitely don't feel stupid because first off, I don't have the box.
I'm sure somebody's somebody got mad at me.
Like the moment I brought it up.
Yeah. They were like, Oh, how do these people not know?
And it's like, guys, we're just playing video games.
All right. It's not that serious.
I think the director of the FBI listens.
So he's probably upset that we didn't know.
Yeah. Whoever that is at the current moment, they seem to be changing so frequently.
The dystopic future of this podcast.
Right. Yeah.
Um, okay.
Everybody feel like they got what they needed out of Hogan's alley.
I think I got, I got the Hogan's alley experience.
Right. Okay. So with that, let's step out of Hogan's alley and into the essential games list.
All right.
It's time for the essential games list.
You know how this works.
PS4, PC, got these great games.
You look at 10 say for shim.
Yeah. You got Shin Megami Tensei four on the Nintendo 3DS.
And you're like, wow, I'm playing a pretty old game as it is.
But what if I went even further back and played a game like Hogan's alley, uh, that required me to buy a CRT, uh, that's really heavy.
Um, and would possibly provide me with a few hours of entertainment where Shin Megami Tensei four can only give me like 40 to 60 hours on a good day.
Uh, well, specific viewer.
I mean, listener.
Yeah. Well, exact specific listener, uh, and those who haven't turned off the show yet.
Uh, that's what the essential games list is here to tell you.
It's here to tell you whether this game is worth shutting off Shin Megami Tensei four, but eventually going back to it's a pretty good game.
Uh, but whether it's worth shutting it off and checking out Hogan's alley on the NES, not because it was good back in its day, but because it's good right now.
So we're going to do a vote, uh, two out of three, since there's three of us, it's going to take at least two people to get this thing on the list.
Sean, let's have at it.
Where are you putting this on the list?
Um, it's definitely, definitely an essential, but, um, I think if you had followed our advice, uh, to get duck hunt, um, which is a gold essential.
It's essential gold.
Um, you may as well like get another game.
Yeah. You should only own like one, like you bought the zapper.
I mean like, yeah, you bought enough.
So I mean like it's, it's there.
It's a, it's fun.
Um, so yeah, but it's not on the list.
Especially if you're into the high score element in duck hunt.
Maybe, maybe you'll be more into that in Hogan's alley.
And maybe you want to be a bad enough dude to be on the FBI.
So there you go.
Right. Joe? Yeah, actually.
So I, I think this game is really fun and, uh, I, I, I liked it a lot and I was, it wasn't until I kind of realized that, uh, that my aiming didn't really matter.
It was more about the decision making, which is fun, but I didn't need the zapper and I could just play, let me play like a click game or something.
Um, that I decided that's probably not on my essential list.
It is. Well, it is not on my essential list, but I, I didn't really think about what, uh, what Sean just said.
Since duck hunts on the essential list, I know you all bought your CRT and everything for duck hunt.
So this is a good bonus to have.
And it's definitely worth playing.
If you, if you have this, if you have the equipment that you need, um, definitely worth playing.
And I don't know if we said it in the duck hunt episode, but you do absolutely need a CRT.
You cannot play it on an HD TV.
Right. That's worth noting.
This game for me can't be on the essential games list because it's barely an essential game.
Even back then, like, like it's, there's not enough there.
It's almost disappointing that this game came out at the same time as duck hunt and offers so much little compared to duck hunt.
Um, like I, like I said to Sean earlier, it, it feels like a bunch of mini games.
Whereas like, I'm not saying duck hunt was like this immersive full story game.
That's duck hunt too. Um, but you know, duck hunt kept getting harder and offering like more challenge and like the aiming really felt like, you know, like something that you, something you had to do was an active participation.
Whereas in this game, the only real decision is, you know, is that, is that a gangster or is that, you know, like, well, so like, you know, why are they gangsters?
I'm not going to get into that. That's not, that doesn't make it essential or not.
You know, just like if that guy's wearing a jacket or be shirtless, that doesn't make it essential.
Um, what makes this game in essential to me is that quite frankly, it just doesn't offer enough.
Yeah. Back then, let alone right now.
I think like if, if duck hunt was going to be the game that like, you were going to convince your dad to play with you.
Um, this would be the game that like, you would, you'd get to convince like your uncle, your really weird uncle that like, just want, he wanted to be a cop, but he can't because of his knee.
Right. I don't know if you guys remember the Willy Wonka character, um, Mike TV.
He was the, yeah, he was the guy who was really into Westerns.
Yeah. Oh yeah.
I feel like he would have loved Hogan's alley.
Like, you know, shooting up the bad guys.
Um, and that's just like, you know, that's my little shout out to Mike TV.
If you're listening to Mike TV, pick up a copy of Hogan's alley.
I think he actually, I think he does appearances.
Yeah. This is, this is like post show territory, but I'm pretty sure he does like appearances as Mike TV and like signs autographs for like Willy Wonka related stuff.
Uh, super weird. Anyway, uh, that's been the essential games list.
It's definitely, uh, not essential for Hogan's alley.
Uh, I don't even know, uh, real fast.
Do you guys feel like it's worth playing?
I think you kind of said yes.
If you own duck hunt.
Yeah. I mean, if you already got a light gun, sure.
I think it's, I think it's, uh, you know, I think you're going to see everything you can in 25 minutes with this game.
So I don't know what it's worth.
I don't know if I would say it's, it's a skip for me.
I would say it's worth playing, but not essential.
All right. And that's all the time we have for this episode of nostalgia.
Join us next time for ice climbers and be sure to play it yourself.
If you can for more nostalgia, please subscribe to our podcast, wherever you listen and be sure to check out nostalgia cast.com.
That's N E S T A L G I A cast.com.
There you'll find links to the show and show notes, as well as our other platforms, such as Twitch, YouTube, Twitter, and Facebook.
Thank you so much for your support of nostalgia.
We thank you for spending time with us.
I'm Michael Esposito.
You can find me on at Esposito film on Twitter, and I'll talk to you soon.
And I think we've got some time for the post show.
Yeah, we do.
We're bringing it back. Let's get a post show in.
I'm going to be talking real fast guys. Uh, I would like, uh, you know, it seems like even though I didn't plan this, like I just thought they were gangsters.
But now since it's like the FBI and you're like taking them down and stuff like that, maybe we could just talk about some gangster films.
Yeah, we could do that.
Joe, you Joe, are you a gangster film guy?
Uh, you know, I could, I mean, I like the Godfather.
I like, you know, some mafia films.
I like, uh, Goodfellas and stuff.
Goodfellas is like what I'm thinking of as I was playing Hogan's album.
A little bit of Home Alone 2.
Yeah, yeah, a little bit like a mix between Home Alone 2.
It gave me more of a Home Alone 2 vibe.
Uh, did you find the wet bandits in here?
The redheaded guy kind of looks like, uh, what's his name?
Joe Pesci? Oh yeah, the other guy.
Okay, good. I was like, Joe Pesci.
That guy has a legendary scream.
Joe Pesci? No, no, no, no.
The other guy. I only know his character name.
Yeah, yeah. Well, I'm just going to continue to call him the other guy.
Joe Pesci and then there's the other guy.
Yeah. The one thing I noticed in there too was the, uh, there's the guy that looks like the cop
that has the sunglasses.
Sorry to get back into the game.
No, it's okay. The guy that looks like the cop that has the sunglasses and then there's the cop and I'm
kind of like, hey cop, there's a bunch of bad guys around.
Instead of just standing there smiling at me, he's just like, hi guys.
Yeah, he's like smiling too.
Yeah. Um, yeah, I don't want to get back into the game.
Um, but I never, I never, I, Joe, I never felt bad about anything cause it's, they're
clearly not real. Like not even just the fact that they're in a video game.
I don't mean to be shit like that.
Like I'm talking about like, yeah, they're, they're cardboard, you know, they're just
training. They're even less real than most video games.
They know couldn't let you actually shoot things.
Ducks are fine. Ducks are all, you know.
Yeah. Like, like you said training, like what if they made a training day game?
Like where you. For the NES?
Well, no, uh, maybe.
I mean, we could do a ROM hack or something like that.
You know, Ducks Hunt 2 has become such a big part of this podcast that like, I kind of
just want us to continue to explore like the modernizations of these games.
Like the modern Hogan's Alley is like a sick open world Grand Theft Auto style thing where
you're like. But everybody's made of cardboard.
Yeah, but everybody's made of cardboard and it's, yeah, so it's like a mix between
like super hot.
Where like they only move when you move.
Oh no, it's also like a horror game.
Yeah. Like scary cardboard.
But you're in like an FBI training facility on, on Mars.
Okay. It's not going to be on Mars.
I think it would be kind of terrifying to have like hyper realistic moving cardboard
cutouts. Yeah.
This is like you're, you're alone.
I love how like we always, we always bring Nintendo stuff back to hyper realistic graphics.
Like if there's one thing that Nintendo switch can't do, it's hyper realistic graphics.
I don't know. I just think that like Hogan's Alley 2 should be, should be a movie.
It could be a movie.
Um, I'm, I'm thinking more of like a survival horror game, uh, where they're already like
moving when you're not looking.
Okay. Um, but you're also the only person left in the facility.
I kind of like that. I do, I do also think though, just to get back to the movie real fast, Hogan's Alley 2,
right? Yeah. Is actually, and it's a movie and this is the first one that comes out.
It's just Hogan's Alley 2.
Cause everybody knows that Hogan's Alley 1 is the NES game.
And at the end of the NES game, you passed your training and now Hogan's Alley 2 is like,
you know, that's like the actual movie where you're, yeah, you're in the FBI and you have
to basically what you find out is, is that the cardboard gangster guys that were in that
thing, they're actually like real people.
Like voodoo dolls.
I like where you're going.
Uh huh. Guys, we are making a movie on the fly.
Yeah. This is happening.
Yeah. Okay. So fine.
They're voodoo dolls and you've killed them.
And now you're wanted by the own agency that you've been, that you joined.
Oh man. So this is like fugitive.
Oh, so you've killed, you've killed the people that these voodoo dolls are representing.
Right. And now you're a wanted criminal.
But they enabled you to do that.
Was it a trap that they set on you that like, they made you kill these guys?
It had to be. Right, right. It's an inside job.
Yeah, it's an inside job.
What you basically find out is that the head of the FBI is corrupt.
Wow. They're all corrupt.
Yep. Wow.
I'd watch gangster movies.
Yeah, gangster movies.
This was a great post show about gangster movies.
Just if you want some quick recommendations of some gangster films, the name is Martin Scorsese.
The one we're making is the- You literally just watch any of his films.
It don't even have to be gangster films.
Just watch like After Hours.
Like, it's not a gangster film, but we'll talk about it.
Like, Sidney Lumaine's network.
Yeah. Right.
The Dark Knight.
You know what's funny? I pulled that one out of my hat, but if I think about it-
Yeah, that was a kind of a gangster film.
Yeah. You know? What's funny about that movie, what I think is funny is the boat, right?
Yeah. The two boats and the buttons and everything like that, right?
It's like we both know, both.
We both know, and Joe via satellite know, that if that happened in the real world, those buttons would be clicked.
Pressed immediately. Oh my God.
But here's a bigger problem with that whole thing though.
Wouldn't the explosion of the one of the things cause the other button to like somehow be pushed and detonate them as well?
Oh, that was the actual boats.
I think that would be the strategy. If you're steering the boat, steer it near the other one so then you know, mutually-
Let me say that again.
Mutually assured destruction. Joe, we don't cut in the post show, right?
Just own it and get through with it.
All right. Everyone will know I couldn't say that phrase, which I'm not going to say now.
I never drink water during the show, so I'm just going to take advantage of it during the post show.
You're letting yourself go, Mike.
Do you want the listeners to know what you sound like when you're drinking water?
I guess not. Sorry, guys.
That's the only time you're going to be able to hear that.
That's kind of gross. That's been the post show.
It's been a mess. That's why we haven't done it for a couple of episodes.
It's been any mess.
Any- Whoa. Okay.
Let's just cut. All right.
Let's just cut. Sam, can you sign me out of the computer? Okay. Thank you.